we're here all here to talk about the
electronic triple it's on in two weeks
time I mean what day is today tuesday in
two weeks from today we will be
knee-deep in press conferences yeah
we'll have well we'll have all the info
yeah nintendo's the last thing and then
that's it well they're just gonna talk
about zelda anyways so will we all know
two weeks from this moment we will know
what zelda what that new zelda is yeah
that's exciting what it looks like well
we kind of know what it looks like what
they meant for it to look like ish so
let's talk about some of the stuff
before we get into the sort of
speculation area let's talk about some
of the stuff that we know dead on is
actually going to be at e3 I guess yeah
first of all legends of Zelda on the way
you let's get the ball rolling Alex are
you excited for this yes uh big zelda
fan to replate twilight princess when it
came out we played majora's mask um I
don't think I'm as big of a like diehard
is Mike though hmm Mike I like Zelda
liya pretty calm for this especially
I've like watch that I numa and Miyamoto
video where they first showed it yeah a
lot a few times and I just the idea of
it after like playing a link between
worlds which is pretty open world ish
I'm pretty excited to see what they
would do on you know wii u NX whatever
happens to be on yes that's the one
thing i guess the caveat in this is that
we do know that they're not going to be
showing NX in any form yeah so we're
gonna see the wii u version of it I'm
will you honor like I feel like it was
worth picking up for some of the games
and Ron there is a great little catalog
small but dense quality wise you know
catalog of games are you disappointed
that we won't see it on the NX yeah it
felt like dead on for months that we
were going to see that console this year
yeah definitely especially with all the
talk that you know microsoft's having
about to use the xbox one whether it's
the stream box or the smaller Xbox one
whatever happens the I'm about or the PS
4.5 it's kind of a shame to see Nintendo
not you know pulling out their big guns
the same time because you know they're
usually like a year ahead on hardware at
least not that it's better when they
release it but there in terms of
announcements usually you're ahead so
it's kind of looking forward to that it
also kind of i'm hoping begs a question
whether the new zelda will be kind of
like the twilight princess thing like
wii u and NXT i hope it's not I'd rather
them just let us going to come out on
both ya did ya yes sorry I I hope that
doesn't detract from the game itself
right has to be on two different
platforms I
of ideally like it just to be on the NX
obviously you know it's not gonna happen
but I don't gotta worry now only honest
yeah I guess yeah well you know it
depends it begs the question whether yet
is the NX like actually really close to
a you know normal console d-pad buttons
kind of thing or is it this sort of
strange new thing and maybe they don't
show the next version because it is
widely different I mean yeah that's kind
of what we're hoping for I'm just like
so I know I know a lot of people i know
a lot of evil indie developers and other
developers and i talked to them and
they're like oh yeah nintendo approached
me about developing for the NX and we
said okay what are the specs in nintendo
said we're not giving them to you really
so nintendo isn't even giving specs to
like some developers so strange well how
do you develop or something yeah you
don't know what it is yeah but make a
game for it yeah make a game them
figured out later I mean it's not like
they've ever had a problem with
third-party development on their
consoles right let's move on and next
one I'll here's one for you like so
final fantasy 15 that's comments
accepted land of september's come to an
end of September I will not be playing
it on launch day because i'll be at a
wedding so oh really yeah Tommy member
uh no uh-uh in Germany Oh wonderful yeah
um how dare they do that they work in
the games industry they should know
better i love them i do i'll do it for
her um ya know 10 years like this is the
reason that i am that game is the reason
i'm sitting here because i watched the
launch trailer for vs 13 rice 2006 on it
on a old-ass mac apple computer in my
high school I past someone in the
hallway they were like oh a new final
fantasy got announced sounds like what
so I ran to the computer I'll haven't
watched it I was like I want to write
about this stuff and now here I am it's
coming out 10 years later and I'm a
grown woman who pays bills and can now
spend lots of money and collector's
editions right these games nice work and
what do you hope you see because we've
already seen a feeling at easton ma
we've played it in fact yeah um I mean
combat I think we have a handle on I
think we have a handle on sort of oh
like it's a it's a war between countries
um I want to see more of like the
cooking and and and magic like we've
seen some magic spells but not how you
like level up magic and stuff right I
want to know more about the characters
they announced all these characters
here's her character here's her name and
we're not gonna talk about her and I
kind of want to know more about these
characters because that's what defines
that series so uh that that's what
defines final fantasies people find
character and they're like oh like this
is the person identify with or they're
very very special or they have some sort
of hero's journey thing going on and I
feel like we don't know enough about
anyone outside of the four main dudes
yeah and I would love to like I want to
know more about Luna and gentiana who's
shown once never shown again that really
sexy badass dragon lady you want the
nitty-gritty I want the needy give me
everything right now add a gamer I'm
really looking forward to which is being
developed actually relatively close up
in Tiburon by 2k is Matthew 3 and made
this is the sort of very sort of
interesting take on a mafia and I love
what they're doing with this like I
really like the Murphy series it's
always been a sort of interesting I mean
the first one I think is absolutely like
PC classic adored it an interesting take
on a sort of open world game in a way
that sort of I guess games like LA noire
kind of later managed to dip their toe
in but this one set a new Bourdeaux
african-american protagonist dealing
with sort of very interesting a sort of
racial issues around I mean the whole
idea of like taking this away from the
Mafia and calling a mafia game itself
shows you how Boulder being with this
either you guys excited for Matthew
three yeah I played it for three hours a
couple months ago one is it pretty one
gamespot.com yeah um no I'm really
excited for it like open world games are
a little daunting to me but hmm I really
like the way that that world is a flesh
out and the way it feels it feels really
lived in and that's what's got me very
interested for this one more beer self
monkey yeah I really like period piece
games he dries le noir and then but for
a while it's just been Assassin's Creed
essentially then you have you have 0
like one other like The Saboteur which
yes is overlooked a lot which I like but
Irishman Paris yeah yeah so I'm really
looking forward to mafia threes New
Orleans setting a because that's pretty
unexplored in games there are games set
there but I'm really looking forward to
how they actually flesh out historically
the setting because that's always
appealing to me like actually kind of
living in that environment yeah always
enjoyed we're running out of cities in
North America to go into as well so it's
got a Syracuse or something yeah yeah
Syracuse circle senait square miles of
it speaking of places outside of north
america Mass Effect Andromeda coming out
2017 and we've seen hardly any of this
game we saw like a weird developer diary
where they showed off like it they [ __ ]
they teased as little as you could
possibly to use I feel like this game
are we just going to see gameplay d3 is
a time I mean they have to if that thing
is coming out that thing is coming out
in spring of next year like this is the
time to show it it's either here or
gamescom and I feel like they would be
depending on based on what EA has now
but we know they have what they're
showing like they would be foolish to
not roll that out at e3 yeah I think I
mean I love gamescom but you don't add
something this big or show off something
this big necessarily at Gamescom this is
basically they're sort of ace in the
hole I mean yeah you're working actually
now working on a lot of very interesting
action games but yeah it's sort of a bad
time they show this one off I'm like
yeah it's kind of also worrying when a
lot of key talent left right jack Wow
three months ago or so so that kind of
had me worried delays I don't I don't
look at it as bet necessarily bad guys
but yeah I'm curious to see where it
goes they did the teaser trailer just
showed wasn't like the main character
looking at a galactic map right with the
ghostwriters chiller really yeah because
the Johnny Cash song ghost riders and
already playing in a match I've since
seen like via someone's linkedin or
something that there was some footage of
like the technical aspects of the game
which showed some interesting sort of
player movement yeah so probably at that
time and that's run all through
somebody's a little bit quicker at
titanfall to come on a cue for this year
tootin fall we're all have you been more
time to fall right yeah do we want a
campaign and this one's a bit more
fleshed out we have we can say much it
there yeah yes I'd only playing with
other people so give me a campaign fair
enough yeah also Vincent Bella pretty
good at making sinclair games and self
and jason west obviously with the
college view franchise yeah okay we're
all in agreement next up Deus Ex mankind
divided also coming out relatively quick
at the end of august august twenty-third
and I'm a massive Deus Ex fam the first
two games especially the first game
absolute classic didn't really get into
the the new one but I know there's a lot
of fans out there either you guys yeah I
liked even revolution a lot had
definitely flaws in how you can actually
choose your path through it and how you
get screwed over in the end but yeah I'm
pretty fun for mankind divided like all
these games have mentioned today this
one also confirmed to show at e3 and
what do they need to do with this
because it's been a little while it's
been like four years maybe since i'm
trying to think when human revolution
with my life yeah came out in 2011
Google August 2011 yes it'll almost be
45 years to the day almost since that
God I didn't realize it was that far
away and why don't even have to do with
this do they just need to do the same
again or like did I'm I don't think they
need to go towards any sort of like
making the levels particularly bigger
anything like they just have to iterate
on me they thought what they did they
did really well I so long as their
iteration is like smart and fun like I
haven't played it yet i don't know if
you've gotten a chance to play it at all
no but i'm really hoping that's actually
a similar case with dishonor to because
dishonored one and a human revolution
both to me had the same problem of the
kind of purport to let you go through
the game however you want whether myself
or combat but both of those games kind
of leads you toward combat as you keep
playing I'm hoping both those games you
know not to jump into bethesda quickly
but I hope both those games correct that
so you can actually actually go through
the game high one because I like stealth
and I don't want to feel like I have to
be upping my armor and my damage in my
explosives the whole time yeah I mean
that was massive problem with dishonours
yeah it was sort of tried to be thief
and then ended up being you know more of
an action game I'm the same problem with
Deus Ex the first one was especially the
boss fights you mean you can't stealth
the boss fights and now sort of run into
a problem here but since you mentioned
it dishonor to they're also coming at
this year in November 11th 2016 excited
about when the Alexa yes that game looks
beautiful hmm also i think the narrative
narrative designer is cara else Ellison
oh yeah of course she's actually X Games
bad journalism yeah she's an awesome
writer so I'm actually really excited to
see where that goes because of for a
moment yeah she'd be good stuff yeah I'm
hoping I'm curious about the interplay
between Emily and Corvo and how playing
through the game definitely has them
right actually affect it because you
know dishonored one you can go like we
said pretty different paths whatever
better or worse but this one I'm like
like four paths if you play both of them
differently each time I mean both their
abilities are pretty distinct but I'm
looking forward to trying that out for
sure yeah last two big guns i have on
this are call of duty infinite warfare
coming at november 4 2016 i'm guessing
we're going to see gameplay of this
alexa probably yeah excited all Mike oh
yeah sorry you were in concussion Lander
all this stuff looks about it I
learn about it um that the game director
and that is the former is the game
director who ditched me to rise of the
Tomb Raider oh right okay yeah
interesting that's so I follow people oh
yeah interested in it for that but so
somebody who's good at rebooting
franchises which have become tired over
time yeah interesting excited about this
Mike I'm curious and hopeful for that
yeah flatout excited for battlefield one
that's the other one that's not my
october 21st it's going to be a good two
weeks before infinite warfare drops yeah
like so what did you think when you
first saw this could weave did all the
reaction visas in the whole place we
talking about it for a week so you
didn't get to enjoy any of that what did
you think of you saw battlefield going
back to well not going back going for
the first time to the trenches of World
War one well my so i might young my
little brother who's 10 years younger
than me abandoned the battlefield series
right it started getting a little too
futuristic and he loves period pieces
and he's like and he said to me like a
year ago and he was like i'll play that
game if it goes back to World War one
right like the first thing that happened
when I saw that was like all right Jake
I think it's really cool I think that's
a really awesome a min convention is
very bold yeah yeah um I think it looks
really cool mikey is a scholar of Roman
we learned no one in the office knew
this apparently he studied in university
yeah went to school what does that
surprise I went to school as love and I
learned about making websites not bloody
world war 1 50 study journalism this was
like a passion the minor I don't
romanticize the work is terrible war
when humankind realized we should chill
the fuckis stop doing it justice yeah uh
i'm actually i'm really excited the
multiplayer Rob and I have like plans
he's I'm gonna be his gunner he's gonna
be flying the biplane and that's because
I have to see the gameplay they showed
us at the event oh yeah yeah so I like
they're showing like the plane diving
like 180 degrees to the ground and then
sorry 90 degrees I didn't study math I'm
not a guy just firing up in the air 90
and um he's flying 180 degrees to the
ground ya know us but i am i'm really
excited for the story too because they
mentioned the Harlem Hellfighters would
be such a badass thing to show and they
said there be different people from
different parts of the war and I doin a
horsewoman as well and also like I'm
sure that like the Christmas truce and
maybe the Marne will be
oh yeah you do what you think there's
gonna be like a football minigame Oh
Alex new house that message me because
he's you know like him being into
history and stuff he's a dude what if
they like shut down the servers on
Christmas so you can like God oh yeah
that'd be so clever on also everyone
would hate them oh yeah like the one day
everybody's home and can play games but
or they just mod the servers that
everyone's playing football instead
Debbie I guess boots up FIFA they could
do that to you say that da they can like
they scanned it exists a skin to FIFA
teams in like like Hans and but for
pointed helmets and that's like put your
water cool oh you'll know that's such a
good idea you go yeah that's a freebie
EA and that's all the games that are
confirmed for well the big games that
are confirmed for e3 Legend of Zelda
mafia 3 Mass Effect titanfall to their
sex mankind divided the sauna to called
you the infinite warfare battlefield uno
and Final Fantasy 15 so let us in the
comments which one you're most excited
about